successful economies and cultures are
built on trust but a number of
high-profile data breaches and privacy
intrusions have caused anxiety for
consumers and gotten the attention of
Washington new legislation may be needed
to bolster confidence in the digital
marketplace but we've got to be
thoughtful about it so we don't strangle
the Golden Goose that we call the
Internet
three points explosive growth of digital
services shows that the benefits of data
flows far outweigh the costs
slow productivity growth in many
industries stems from a lack of
information intensity too little data
policies should thus encourage the use
of more data while putting consumers in
control of sensitive information a new
national privacy law would consolidate
existing industry specific laws prevent
a patchwork of conflicting state laws
and clarified the FTC's enforcement
strategy for the digital age but
regulations cannot solve every problem
evolving social norms more robust
institutions and new privacy promoting
technologies will actually do most of
the heavy lifting of protecting our
privacy and promoting dutiful are you
optimistic or pessimistic about the tech
economy let us know in our poll also let
us know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI